I'm not going to spend a ton of time on
this but Mike Pence has put together a
number of appearances here
um connected of course to the book that
he has written and he
you know he's turned on Trump he's
abandoned Trump Pence has put together a
list of five or so very calculated
statements that he repeats one that
we've heard often is what Trump did was
Reckless on January 6th another one that
he repeats is he endangered my family
these are not accidents these are
workshopped lines where Pence knows he's
going to get these questions and he
works with a team to figure out here's
the things I'm going to say a new thing
that he said yesterday on Fox News was
that there will be better choices for
the Republican nomination in 2024 than
Trump and one of the most interesting
things about this is watching the Fox
Fox and Friends hosts figure out how to
deal with this I honestly believe that
we'll have better choices come 2024. you
know I don't think anybody's choices
than Donald Trump I do yeah we will have
better choices than Donald Trump so the
question Still Remains of course if the
nominee in 24 is Donald Trump will you
vote vote for him I have no reason right
now to believe that the answer is no I
think much like William Barr who
criticized Trump up and down for a dozen
different things and then when it came
to well but would you vote for him if
he's the nominee and he's like well yeah
Democrats are a disaster I'm not voting
for a Democrat I think despite all this
despite Pence's anger that Trump
endangered his family
he still hasn't said if Trump is the
nominee I will not vote for him and I
think that he will
um one other interesting anecdote from
yesterday's interview with Fox
um he talked about I get my
understanding is this is the last time
he spoke to Trump and I went into his
office and uh
I I after he made inquiries about Karen
and Charlotte who'd been with me at the
Capitol the entire time on January 6th
all the way until four in the morning
yeah
um he asked me uh he asked me what I
felt that day and I told him I was angry
we had our differences and
seeing those people ransacking the
capital infuriated me I
my my only thought was not this not here
not in America right but we I was very
candid with him we were very
straightforward with each other I I
sensed in the president as I write it
genuine remorse about what had happened
in the days that followed that
we spoke again and again in the two
weeks remaining of the administration
what's funny about I sense genuine
remorses as recently as last month or
two weeks ago Trump made clear he
doesn't have remorse he repeated all the
same stuff that infuriated his followers
about Mike Pence I I also Trump has
never expressed remorse about anything
none of this all seems made up
but on that day that you ask about
um
I sense the president was still
saddened by what had occurred
and I just reminded him as I had at the
beginning of our first conversation that
I was praying for
I prayed for that President almost every
day during our Administration
and he was dismissive about it at first
don't don't bother but then as I a few
minutes later as I got up to leave the
room I looked at him as he sat at the
end of the little table in the dining
room just off the Oval Office
and I said well I guess there's just two
things we're probably always going to
disagree on
and he looked up at me and
faintly said what
and I said refer to my role on January
6.
and then I said
I'm never going to stop praying for you
and he looked at me and
and said that's right don't don't ever
change yeah and we parted amicably does
anybody believe that story and and the
the biggest lie seems to be the last
thing we parted amicably Trump doesn't
part amicably with people he just
doesn't but I don't believe a word of
that story so it's an interesting
anecdote because it's the opposite of
everything that we know Trump to be he
wants to sell books we'll see what
happens in 2024. one of our sponsors is
Helix sleep I have been sleeping on a
helix mattress for years and I always
recommend it to friends you'd simply
take this Helix sleep quiz it asks you
about your body type your sleep position
whether you have back pain and then
Helix will match you up with the
mattress that is personalized to your
needs and they ship it to you for free
another reason I went with Helix is that
unlike a lot of mattress companies out
there every single Helix mattress is
made in the USA by a skilled production
team which means when you buy a helix
mattress you're supporting great jobs
I'm not the only one who loves Helix
Helix was recently awarded number one
mattress by both GQ and Wired Magazine
every Helix mattress comes with a 10 or
15 year warranty you can try it a
hundred nights and send it back for a
full refund if you need to support the
David pakman show by getting your next
mattress from Helix sleep and and you'll
get up to three hundred and fifty
dollars off any mattress plus two free
pillows when you go to helixsleep.com
Pacman the link is down below